TIM STÜTZLE WAS PICKED THAT SAM
BRANNSTROM SPINS AND SHOOTS,
SHESTERKIN GOT THE BLOCKER DOWN
AND KNOCKED THE LAST NINE GAMES
INCLUDING A GOAL LAST NIGHT.
TIM STÜTZLE GETS IT BY
SHESTERKIN AND OTTAWA LEADS  SH
STÜTZLE TO FIND THE BACK OF THE
HE GETS ONE HERE COMING IN.
NOW TROUBA IN, SHOOTS, AND
GUSTAVSSON HAD TO MAK
SCHNEIDER FOUND STROME AND THE
RANGERS TIE IT AT 1-1. SLOT.
HE WAITS A LITTLE BIT, AND ABLE
BASEBALL AND SEWED A CUP ON IT
TO MAKE THE GLOVE THAT WE NOW
BACK-TO-BACK GAMES, A TOTAL OF .
KREIDER LOST THE PUCK.
PAUL WIT
>> Gord: IN COMES JULIEN
GAUTHIER, A FORMER FIRST ROUND
PICK OFamie: THAT'S HOW THE BRU
PLAY AND THEOOKMENT TAKES IT FR
FOREHAND TO BACKHAND.
THIS ISNT.
BACK AT THE POINT IS
TROUBLE?
THE RANGERS.
UIT AND DOING ANALYSIS YOU
HAVE TOPENALTY-FREE PENALTY, PL
THE NORTH/SOUTH GAME TO HOLDEN,
FIND THE STICK OF PAUL,OUND, GO.
THAT'S THAT.
FOX BACK TTEAM.
>> Jamie: WOW.
TOO.EZ BIG STRONG GUY IN
IT DROPS DOWN TO CHRIS
ZIBANEJAD, WORKS IT BACK AROUND
POWER PLAY.
ZIBANEJAD, DOWN TO STROME, TO S.
SIDE UNDER THE BAR TO GIVE THE
RANGERS A  LINE AND
SWINGS BACK.
STILL NO KAAPO KAKKO WHO MISSED
THE LAST NINE GAMES NOW WITH ANT
BACK. PEOPLE CALL
>> Jamie: IT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO GET FOO A HABITGTON.
BRANNSTROM WORKS IN.
DROPS THAT BACK TO TIERNEY.
TIERNEY SPINS AND SHOOTS,,
TEMPO A LITTLECK SHOT, AND SHESE
IN FRONT FOR PANARIN.
GOOD DEFENCE AT THE LAST SECOND.
THIS IS T COULDN'T CONNECT ON
THAT! NINE GAMES.
THINK BACK TO THAT GAME AGAINST
ST. LOUIS, DOWN ET IT DOWN TO T
THE NET.